if you want to hear the three by far
scariest things to have ever existed in
the wizarding world then stick around to
the end of this video
welcome to creepy things a series where
i take a look at some of the scariest
moments in non-horror franchises and
analyze what makes them so frightening
the harry potter franchise has always
been known for having some of the most
disturbing creatures so let's start by
exploring a few of those this will
contain spoilers for the harry potter
series not everything i discuss is
inherently harmful but that doesn't mean
fans won't find it creepy when it comes
to thestrals i find it perfectly
understandable that people would be put
off by them thestrals are bony skeletal
horses with huge bat wings and
reptile-like faces with expressionless
eyes in addition to their sinister
appearance they only appear to those
that have witnessed and comprehended
death in the sense they exist as a
metaphor for grievance
someone who has witnessed death may try
to explain their appearance to another
but it would be impossible to appreciate
how creepy they are without witnessing
death and seeing them for yourself
this is also the reason that harry
potter and luna lovegood are able to
bond over the fact that they can both
see thestrals because both have suffered
and they can understand each other's
pain the thestrals at hogwarts are well
trained and responsible for transporting
the threshold-drawn carriages around
campus
however thestrals in the wild can be
much more dangerous they are described
to have sharp fangs and season slash
their prey they are extremely
intelligent and as we see when luna goes
out to feed the thestrals they are
carnivorous and attracted to the smell
of blood
trolls one of the first creatures
encountered in the series they can be
about 12 feet tall way over one ton and
have immense strength the characters
encounter a troll set loose into
hogwarts their first year the troll was
set loose by professor quirrell in an
attempt to create a distraction so that
he could steal the sorcerer's stone
or philosopher's stone depending on
where you're from the creepiest part
about the troll is the sound that it
makes
[Music]
trolls aren't capable of intelligent
language so their cries are really just
expressions of their hunger for human
flesh
that's right these things may not be the
smartest but they actually eat people so
you can only imagine how scary it is for
a child as young as 11 years old to have
to take one of these on alone
this incident also took place on
halloween so also not knowing if this
was some kind of cruel first-year prank
or an actual attack is also bound to
cause anxiety
one good thing to come out of it was
that the scary incident may have been
what brought harry ron and hermione
together as friends but there would be
many more far scarier opponents in the
future
not many first year students could take
on a fully grown mountain troll and live
to tell the tale
cerberus
a cerberus only ever appears during
harry's first year the one encountered
is a giant three-headed dog with sharp
teeth very aggressive and very
territorial the whole point of having
this dog is to scare students away and
the dog was the guard of a door leading
to the philosopher's stone
the only thing that's not scary about
this creature is its name fluffy there
are two main factors that make fluffy
creepy first is that the students are
not told that he's there to guard a door
only that they are forbidden from
entering the room fluffy falls asleep in
the presence of music so trying to sneak
past him is extremely nerve-wracking
because it's hard to say when he might
wake up and attack
does it seem a bit
quiet to you
the heart
it stopped playing
the tale of the three brothers this book
is a fairy tale that witches and wizards
apparently tell to their young as a
supposed backstory of the deathly
hallows the most powerful tools in the
wizard world
why any parent would tell this
horrifying tale to their young children
who can't even read yet is completely
beyond me but nonetheless ron claims
that learning this tale from a very
young age is commonplace
the story is about three brothers who
cheat death yes the grim reaper and are
each allowed one wish as a prize the
first gets the elder wand the most
powerful wand in existence the second
gets a resurrection stone to bring
someone back to life and the third
brother the wisest of the three gets the
cloak of invisibility to evade death in
the future
but that's not the scary part the first
brother uses the elder wand to kill a
wizard he didn't like but because he
boasted about the power of the wand
someone came and slit his throat in the
knights to steal it the second brother
is the most disturbing though he uses
the resurrection stone to bring back his
dead girlfriend she not belonging to the
world of the living appears in a cold
sad state which eventually derives the
brother to kill himself
think about the implications of this
harry uses the resurrection stone to
bring himself back after he allows
voldemort to kill him in the forest that
means it's possible that if the effects
of taking someone back from death are
true then harry will be miserable for
his remaining days possibly driving his
wife and three kids mad with his
condition
now that doesn't look to be the case
based on his behavior in the epilogue
but it's entirely possible that this
will kick in when his natural life span
is up and jenny's final days with harry
will be filled with misery until harry
seeks his own tragic death
while we're on the topic of death it
seems that death is not always the end
in the world of wizards there are many
ghosts present in the series most of
them are completely friendly and not
really creepy in the slightest
there are however a few exceptions
okay that one's not actually a ghost
that's a spell set by maddai moody in
order to scare off the death eaters from
raiding the house of black while the
order is away
but there are some creepy ghosts at
hogwarts such as helena ravenclaw in
life helena was the daughter of rowena
ravenclaw the founder of the ravenclaw
house after running away from hogwarts
helena's mother became extremely ill and
sent the bloody baron who was in love
with helena to retrieve her not wanting
to go with the baron helena refused and
in a rage the baron killed her leaving
her bitter and angry at everyone outside
of her own house earning her the
nickname the gray lady
in fact the rest of hogwarts doesn't
even believe that helena's ghost can
speak because she's only ever been known
to talk to ravenclaws from time to time
her quiet shy and serene nature makes it
all the more terrifying when you try to
confront her and witness one of her
outbursts i know what he's done i know
who he is he defiled it with dark magic
the last ghost that i'm going to talk
about is not creepy in a horror sense
but i do feel that she deserves a
mention
moaning myrtle is the ghost of a student
who haunts the 2nd floor girls lavatory
at hogwarts she was the lone student
killed during the occurrences of the
1943 school year in which the chamber of
secrets was opened and the monster was
set free by tom riddle
myrtle isn't really a scary ghost per se
but she is creepy in her own way her
reckless emotions are enough that nobody
ever goes into the bathroom she inhabits
and she has a strange fascination with
death for someone stuck in the mental
state of a 14 year old i was
[Music]
myrtle is more seen as creepy because
she doesn't really know boundaries and
from what we can gather she's kind of a
weird kid even before death and tends to
make the students uncomfortable but
moaning myrtle is really just trivial
compared to our next moment of
[Music]
[Applause]
shall be horror
and servant and master shall be reunited
once more
[Music]
yep and just another day in divinations
class with professor trelawny but the
creepy thing here is not professor
trelawny but rather the array of visions
that happen throughout voldemort's rise
to power most of them are visions that
appear to harry because of his
connection with lord voldemort imagine
how horrifying it must be to know that
at any time you might be yanked out of
the here and now and sucked into a
nightmarish image of the world's most
powerful dark force who by the way wants
to kill you
the visions get more and more creepy as
lord voldemort starts to realize that he
and harry are connected and starts to
show him things on purpose in order to
get into his head there's also a pretty
scary scene at the end of order of the
phoenix in which voldemort takes over
harry's body entirely to deliver a
message to dumbledore
one of the things that makes this
universe scary is the fact that powerful
creatures can be found roaming freely
with no real safe havens the mughals
have no idea that dangerous magical
creatures could be among them at any
time there are two examples of such
creatures made most prominent in harry
potter and the prisoner of azkaban the
animagus and the werewolves
both are creatures with human forms and
the ability to transform into beasts the
main difference as taught by professor
snape when he substitutes teaching
defense against the dark arts is that
the anime just have control over their
transformations and have the ability to
turn into a wider variety of animals
whereas werewolves will transform
against their will and will always
transform into a beast similar to a wolf
both can be quite creepy in their own
ways
animages have control over their actions
so clever planning can be used to trick
an unsuspecting victim who thinks that
they're just dealing with an animal it
should be mentioned that many animagists
are not evil but it's also common for
criminals to take advantage of this
ability to escape the law
werewolves can be scary for the opposite
reason though they may be perfectly good
people in their human forms and when the
full moon hits they lose control and
attempt to bite or kill anyone they can
get their paws on werewolves also have
one of the scariest forms while they do
resemble regular wolves their long
gangly limbs are a transformation from
what we would normally expect causing
the werewolves to look like a terrifying
cross between man and wolf combine that
with their sharp carnivorous teeth empty
glowing eyes and the fact that they
appear at night and you have some of the
most dangerous creatures the world has
to offer
we do have more creatures to discuss but
it's not just creepy monsters that harry
and his friends have to deal with one of
the first creepy places that harry
visits is nocturn alley harry
accidentally travels there before his
second year when he mispronounces diagon
alley and is taken there instead like
diagon alley nocturne alley is a
shopping center but the shops are
dedicated to the dark arts as you can
imagine this draws in an interesting
crowd of characters not the crowd that
you want to fall in with before you
start your second year of school
come with us
we'll help you find your way back
but nocturne alley isn't just a mall for
misfit wizards when harry ron and
hermione return to nocturne alley before
their sixth year they eavesdrop on some
kind of ritual going on at a store
called borgen and berks which appears to
be draco malfoy's initiation as a death
eater
borgen and berks is also the store where
tom riddle got his first job after
leaving hogwarts other notable locations
in nocturne alley include a shop that
sells materials related to raising the
dead a shop that sells bones and a shop
that sells shrunken heads the alley is
creepy not only because of its morbid
nature but mostly because of the
horrible people it can attract
the next item is actually a cursed
object that harry encounters almost
immediately upon arriving at nocturne
alley i'm referring to the hand of glory
a severed human hand skeleton with the
power to immobilize those who catch its
gaze and unlock doors this is because
the hand is said to have belonged to an
executed master criminal it only makes a
small cameo appearance in the film
adaptation of harry potter and the
chamber of secrets but with that in mind
harry is lucky to have ever escaped its
grasp the chilling thing about these
objects are the rumors of how they are
created with many myths claiming that
executed criminals blood is used to
animate the hand
stick around because after the break
i'll be discussing an even more shocking
object that harry encounters during his
time at hogwarts
in order to gain more information about
nicholas flamel the creator of the
philosopher's stone harry sneaks into a
restricted section in the library where
this happens
[Music]
the impact of the jump scare is
multiplied by the fact that harry's
sneaking around and we're thinking more
about not getting caught than something
scaring us the agonized face to go along
with it in the film adaptation also adds
to the effect later on towards the end
of the first year harry and the gang go
to retrieve the stone and after getting
past the aforementioned fluffy find
themselves in another trap
devil's snare this is a plant with
magical properties it wraps around its
victim and the level of its constriction
is determined by the panic level of the
victim if the victim relaxes the snare
will relax its grip
they thrive in dark damp environments
making it the perfect trap for a dungeon
devil's snare preys on the fear of
claustrophobia with a critical twist as
fear intensifies so does the threat
creating an endless cycle of increasing
danger if one cannot compose themselves
while caught in the snare this is easier
said than done since those who suffer
from the anxiety disorder of
claustrophobia often have symptoms
including panic attacks or fear of
suffocation
hogwarts is a 10th century gothic style
castle which in many cases can be creepy
in its own right but i'd like to explore
some of the other creepy locations in
the series
the tri-wizard maze during harry's
fourth year at hogwarts an
interscholastic competition known as the
triwizard tournament is held and the
final task is to navigate the tri-wizard
maze an enormous hedge maze with 20-foot
hedges prior to the contestants entering
the maze dumbledore offers them a word
of caution
you see people
change in the maze oh find the cub if
you can but be very wary you could just
lose yourselves along the way
this fits in with the themes of
maturation that arise after the
tri-wizard tournament the students are
growing up into adults and changing to
face the harsh realities of the real
world however as in life the contestants
are not only finding themselves changing
for better or for worse but the world
around them is changing as well the maze
has the ability to reconfigure itself
and those who are not able to adapt are
sucked into its grasp and defeated in
this way the maze combines the fear of
growing up jurassic phobia with the fear
of being lost to create a terrifying
trial for young wizards
i think we've all been creeped out by
the idea of someone living within our
walls at one point or another and if not
i'm sure everyone's gotten a chill from
an abandoned location at some point
these are two reasons why i find the
chamber of secrets to be the creepiest
location in hogwarts the chamber of
secrets is an ancient system of pipes
under the school that housed the monster
of slytherin which of course i'll touch
back on and analyze later in this video
the chamber is so well hidden that even
the teachers and staff cannot find it
and do not believe with full certainty
that it exists the chamber can be
accessed by activating the correct sync
tap while speaking the phrase open up in
parcel tongue after navigating a series
of caves filled with skeletons and
sewage pipes they come across the door
to the inner chamber another line of
snake speak grants access to an enormous
pathway lined with vicious looking snake
head statues and a statue at the end of
an old man's face who i can only assume
is salazar slytherin the founder of the
house and designer of the chamber
salazar was prejudiced against mudbloods
or wizards with muggle parents so
knowing that the chamber was some kind
of layer for those kind of people adds
an additional factor of unsettling
atmosphere
there are so many reasons that the
chamber of secrets is scary primarily
snakes if you find snakes creepy this is
not the place for you
isolation is another reason when harry
and ron are down there nobody knows that
they're there so unlike their previous
adventures no teacher would be able to
bail them out the third reason is
anticipation the horror of the contents
of the chamber is built up over the
course of their second year with creepy
messages being left and scary stories
circulating
finally the true contents of the chamber
are unknown all harry knows is that it's
rumored and probably does contain a
monster so he's always on edge during
his visit if you think the chamber of
secrets seems like an unsafe place for
school children you won't even want to
begin to explore the forbidden forest
also known as the dark forest this
dangerous sprawling woodland could be
the subject of its very own video but in
order to keep things brief let's just
touch on a few of the things that can be
found here
keep in mind this is directly adjacent
to the school there's no fence there's
no spell keeping anything in or out it's
just considered off limits the forest is
home to acromantulas thestrals unicorns
centaurs werewolves hippogriffs and
after the events of year one fluffy but
during the events of year one lord
voldemort did i mention that this is
right next to the school i would never
be able to sleep at night knowing i was
this close to such a dangerous location
but the forbidden forest isn't the only
dangerous location that's right next to
the school stay tuned to hear about the
other one
the great lake is a relatively small
freshwater lake that houses a couple of
the creepiest creatures in harry potter
lore
as if the close proximity to hogwarts
wasn't enough it's also linked with the
school's drain system the lake contains
a couple of species of creepy sea
creatures
merpeople i know mermaids and horror are
not often associated with each other but
these mermaids are not your typical hot
girl attached to a fishtail they're more
like extremely scary fish with a
somewhat humanoid form oh and did i
mention that they have sharp teeth and
sharper pitchforks and they sound like
this
but the merpeople are really the least
of harry's concerns during his
underwater trial in the triwizard
tournament at the bottom of the lake
lies a great evil known as grindelow if
mer people are half man half fish then
grindelow are more like half demon half
octopus and the result is terrifying
they're typically just under five feet
tall making an encounter with one pretty
scary on its own but these creatures
dwell at the bottom of the lake and
attack in swarms they are described as
sickly green creatures with horns and
yes they are actually considered demons
they mostly survive on eating fish or
algae but they're known to eat humans
from time to time they supposedly have
very strong fingers with which they
strangle their prey but perhaps even
more haunting the grindelow are depicted
in folktales to grab little children
standing near the edge of the lake and
pull them down to drown them before
feasting on their insides
horcruxes like the dark forest the
horcruxes are a huge topic to cover
these objects are cursed with a spell
that puts part of the caster inside the
object so that he may not be killed
unless the object is destroyed lord
voldemort has seven of them which is a
lot considering this process can only be
initiated by killing another wizard the
objects themselves are not what i
consider creepy besides the snake that
one's a straight nope but the essences
of voldemort that are released with the
destruction of each one can be pretty
off-putting
perhaps the most creepy incidents of
this and one of the creepiest images in
the series overall is the second to last
horror crux harry potter himself harry
must allow voldemort to kill him in
order to kill the little bit of
voldemort that resides inside of him
harry is taken to the afterlife where we
see this fragment of the dark lord that
binds he and harry together finally die
off
professor snape well okay professor
snape isn't actually that creepy in the
end but his mannerisms have been known
to intimidate students earning him a
reputation neville what frightens you
most of all
sorry
professor snape
as time goes on however this fear does
become less laughable due to the ever
decreasing faith the heroes have in
snape's loyalty to dumbledore the
frightening power he displays and his
duty as a triple agent keeping tabs on
the death eaters snape's harsh nature
and particular disdain for harry potter
may have stemmed from his past being
bullied by harry's father and his
unrequited love for harry's mother
lily's death could help explain his
dislike for light and hopeless demeanor
turn to page 394
did you know the mirror of iriset is
named as such because iris said is the
mirror image of the word desire
dumbledore tells harry that the happiest
person would look into the mirror and
see nothing but their own reflection the
mirror shows the deepest desire whoever
gazes into it harry spends many nights
revisiting the mirror to see the image
of himself with his parents although
this sounds like a happy time of
reflection the mirror may actually be a
great danger to its user
this mirror
gives us neither
knowledge
or truth
men have wasted a way in front of it
even gone mad
to me this is one of the creepiest
objects in the wizarding world because
of these implications monsters are scary
sure but the mirror of irised reflects
more of a psychological horror the
mirror presents the user's greatest
desire regardless of if the desire is an
attainable goal or a fantasy the
euphoria produced by looking into the
mirror is so strong that it starts to
become addictive it dangles an often
unattainable goal before those who look
into it and cause them to lose track of
what's real and what's fantasy once this
happens the person is as good as trapped
trapped in their own mind without the
knowledge or desire to get out perhaps
the scariest part though is that those
with the greatest ambition are the most
vulnerable to it
the next topic is something unlikely to
ever appear to anyone in the mirror
acromantula these giant spiders grow to
over 15 feet long possess giant pincers
and contain extremely toxic venom and
like all too many of the species that
i've discussed love the taste of human
flesh
as if that wasn't already enough these
creatures are intelligent and we know at
the very least that the colony leaders
are capable of speech their ability to
communicate however does not make them
any less savage
my sons and daughters do not harm hagrid
on my command
but i cannot deny them fresh meat when
it wanders so willingly into our midst
goodbye
friend of hagrid
can we panic now yes that would be an
appropriate time to panic even given
their former leader's alliance with
hagrid the acromantula attempt to eat
hagrid right after aragog's death and
still take the more powerful side of
voldemort during the final battle for
hogwarts they don't even make an
exception for their own kind when one
dies the colony eats the corpse until
nothing remains i can appreciate
resourcefulness but the very idea of an
acromantula funeral sends shivers i can
only imagine how ron weasley feels about
all of this
one year after his first encounter with
the colony in the dark forest his
greatest fear is revealed during
professor lupin's defense against the
dark arts class
[Music]
so the acromantula encounter is sure to
be one of the scariest moments for ron
but make sure to keep watching because
up next is a creature that even they are
terrified of
earlier on in this video i mentioned
that the chamber of secrets is home to
the monster of slytherin which harry
assumed was aragog
what he eventually found upon entering
the chamber was that something even more
nightmarish was within the walls of the
castle all along
the monster is the basilisk a massive
50-foot serpent monster with the power
to kill anyone who makes direct eye
contact with it or petrify those who
make indirect eye contact its fangs are
so venomous that they're one of the only
known materials powerful enough to
destroy a horcrux the basilisk is
intelligent cunning and like other
serpents has the ability to speak to
those wizards who understand parcel
tongue its voice makes your skin crawl
[Music]
salazar slytherin who left hogwarts
shortly after co-founding it due to a
disagreement over the acceptance of
mudbloods created the chamber deep under
the school just before departing it was
so well hidden that the teachers began
to accept the idea that it was just a
myth
well
naturally the school has been searched
many times
no such chamber has been found when tom
riddle discovered the chamber as a
hogwarts student he was able to control
the basilisk because he was the last
remaining heir of slytherin he turned it
against the school hurting many and
killing one student myrtle warren who
would later become known as moaning
myrtle since it was riddle who committed
this crime he was able to create his
first horcrux using his diary which
preserved his state at the time until
the next time the chamber was opened
harry potter's second year when harry
ron and hermione decide to investigate
and it'll be dangerous
very dangerous the basilisk is one of
the scariest monsters in the wizarding
world even without the influence of a
dark lord controlling it snakes are
already creepy creatures to begin with
turning it into a giant 50-foot monster
is no exception tom riddle's diary takes
control of ginny weasley to write the
foreboding warning on the walls across
hogwarts and eventually take her
prisoner to feed off of her life force
feeding off of an 11 year old's life
force is always going to be creepy in my
mind when harry and ron get closer to
rescuing her they discover the giant
molded snakeskin that's not a pleasant
thought either harry manages to blind
the beast but that just makes it even
more terrifying somehow because it uses
sound to continue to track harry but the
scariest part in my opinion is when
hermione discovers the method by which
the basilisk gets around the school
pipes
is using the plumbing
what makes this so very unsettling is
that this actually happens in real life
if you have plumbing in your home you're
at the risk of snakes using that to get
into your house and attack you while
you're using the bathroom and this could
happen at any time
when the snake has a deadly magical
stare that fear is doubled or tripled
which is why i believe that harry's
second year had to be one of the
scariest throughout his time at hogwarts
i've already made several references to
voldemort's followers the death eaters a
group of pure blood supremacists who
have sworn their allegiance to the dark
lord like the basilisk it is their
similarities to the real world prejudice
groups that make them creepy along with
their familiarity with the dark arts
despite everything that happens in the
first three years of harry's time at
hogwarts things are relatively under
control compared to the chaos that would
later be set at the quidditch world cup
in 1994 and everything that took place
after the dark pointed robes and torches
send a clear message that this group is
back and the fact that an entire fan
base of wizards are scared off or killed
by the death eaters is a testament to
how feared they actually are
in the voldemort revival ritual the
death eaters take on a cult-like form
and use dark magic of which harry has
never seen the likes like the many real
world groups that they're based on they
use fear as a tactic to claim and retain
their power one of the most frightening
scenes in the entire series takes place
during year 5 at the department of
mysteries the death eaters use their
attire in addition to a voice modulation
spell to ramp up the fear of the unknown
that exists within all of us
we're serious
you know you're really sure not to tell
the difference
between dreams
and reality
another fear tactic they use is the
disruption of order order gives us
comfort and security so by creating
chaos the death eaters instill fear in
massive amounts of people at one time
here's one moment i found particularly
disturbing where the death eaters create
chaos at bill weasley's wedding
the ministry has fallen
minister of magic
is dead
they are coming
they
of course it would be impossible to open
a discussion about the death eaters
without also mentioning the dark lord
himself lord voldemort
tom riddle is a true psychopath even
from an early age flashback scenes to
his childhood reveal his cold evil
persona and his ruthless thirst for
power
like his forefather salazar slytherin
before he sets out to purge those who he
does not consider purebloods his lack of
empathy is truly chilling and his rise
to power is so forceful that most
wizards are too afraid to even mutter
his true name
if not for his encounter with lily
potter it's possible he may have never
been stopped but this important night
drastically weakened voldemort forcing
him to take on a new persona hiding in
the shadows and committing a vile acts
to stay alive like slurping the cursed
blood of the unicorn just for pure life
energy
[Music]
the transformation and revival had
adverse effects on voldemort with each
atrocity he committed using the dark
arts he became more serpent-like losing
his hair flattening his nose
transforming his voice and making him
somewhat of a human monster
with each passing year after his revival
he becomes more and more powerful and
more and more disturbing
it does seem like a lot of his power
comes from fear though his reputation
becomes so great that many of his
opponents have psychologically already
lost the minister of magic himself
refuses to admit that voldemort is back
even when all the evidence is there
because he is in such great denial
one of the only factors that eventually
lead to his defeat is the fact that
harry starts a movement to get hogwarts
students to call voldemort by his real
name without this tide being turned over
the course of harry's education it's
hard to imagine the hogwarts students
standing any chance during the final
battle voldemort's greatest asset really
is fear itself
however there are three more creatures
that i've determined to be even more
terrifying than lord voldemort so be
sure to keep watching to find out what
makes them so scary
before getting to the final three let's
go over a couple of honorable mentions
tom riddle's graveyard classic spooky
graveyard gotta love it the animatronics
in the weasley twins shop absolutely
nightmare fuel getting possessed by a
cursed necklace
[Applause]
and also this one painting in the
prisoner of azkaban and then just the
fact that luna lovegood keeps raw meat
in her purse
okay
final three the creepiest things i've
found in the harry potter franchise
boggertz this shape-shifting species
takes the form of its opponent's
greatest fear
that means bloggers can take the shape
of everything i just mentioned so far in
this video and everything i will mention
in this regard they're even scarier than
lord voldemort because if someone has
something that they fear more than the
dark lord bogarts can take that shape as
well there's really no need to analyze
this one whatever your fear is they will
find it and they will become it i also
find it kind of eerie that nobody has
actually seen the true form of a blogger
because once you've seen one its shape
has already been shifted even a boggart
looking in a mirror would technically
theoretically become its own worst fear
i suppose someone could plant a camera
but as far as i know nobody has and i
can only imagine that the default form
is extremely disturbing
there are only a couple of reasons why
boggers aren't the number one scariest
thing
first you can outnumber them assuming
that your partner doesn't have the same
fear that you have only one would be
affected second the size of the boggart
is limited to the size of the room that
they're in and third assuming that you
know that you're up against the boggart
and not the real thing you can use a
ridiculous charm to vastly weaken it
we've already talked about dark wizards
like the death eaters and lord voldemort
and there's only one type of wizard
that's more horrifying than a dark
wizard a dark wizard that has risen from
the dead
dark wizards have a spell used to
reanimate the corpses of the dead you
may recall that there was a shop
dedicated to necromancy in nocturne
alley however the appearances of the
inferior are much more alarming than
what comes to mind when i think of a
zombie many of them are in a deep state
of decay revealing bone structures but
also containing old traces of skin hair
and flesh to explain why we find these
and similar morbid creatures scary i'll
refer to something known as the uncanny
valley theory an idea that the human
brain is trained to recognize and
process other human faces but when there
are alterations we find them disturbing
because we know that it's wrong the
cloudy white eyes also suggest that the
corpse is not cognizant remember when
trolls were the scariest thing that
harry had to worry about
oh what can change in a short six years
i was also going to include harry's
encounter the year after with bethilda
bagshot at godric's hollow but upon
further investigation that doesn't count
because the corpse wasn't animated using
a spell but it's the same idea
at this point you probably already know
the scariest creature in all of the
wizarding world let's give this some
context when harry encounters the bogger
in professor lupin's defense against the
dark arts class his biggest fear isn't
voldemort the man who killed his parents
and who he's been hearing about for the
better part of the last three years now
no
harry's biggest fear is a dementor a
creature he only once encountered very
recently and briefly on the train but
had such a terrifying experience with it
surpassed even his battle with the
voldemort controlled professor quirrell
and his life-threatening experiences
with the basilisk or acromantula unlike
every other student in the class harry
is not even given the opportunity to
face his fear before professor lupin
steps in to save him the dementors are
floating black cloaked wraith-like
creatures their almost featureless faces
are not often seen and contain only a
large hole with which they suck the soul
out of their victim an experience said
to be worse than death
the dementors are first dispatched from
their post guarding azkaban in order to
find and capture the escapee sirius
black they surround hogwarts during
harry ron and hermione's third year
harry first encounters one on the train
where for some unknown reason it
attempts to suck out his soul upon
arriving at hogwarts professor
dumbledore offers this morning
a word of caution dementors are vicious
creatures they will not distinguish
between the one they hunt and the one
who gets in their way
therefore i must warn each and every one
of you
to give them no reason to harm you
but the dementor appearances become more
frequent throughout the school year
their very presence causes the plant
life around them to immediately shrivel
and die
they exude a radius of cold lifelessness
enough to freeze nearby water as they
pass by
a quidditch match nearly ends in
disaster when harry is once again
targeted by several dementors while
chasing the snitch up in the clouds
during a storm there's only one known
spell that can repel them and it's very
difficult to pull off but harry is able
to perform a patronus charm to ward off
a spiraling swarm of them and save
sirius at the end of the year
harry claims that the dementors force
you to relive your worst nightmares in
his case the final cries of his parents
being murdered by voldemort
up to that point harry already considers
the dementors to be the scariest
encounter of his life and that's why
they're technically still on his side
while trying to find sirius black
but things get even scarier for harry
when he's ambushed by two dementors in
the muggle world before his fifth year a
place where he's supposed to be
relatively safe from magical beings not
long after the allegiance of the
dementors was thrown even more into
question after a mass breakout from
azkaban it would not be long before
harry's worst enemy joined voldemort and
the death theaters in the battle
i think another reason the dementors are
as unsettling as they are besides having
the most sinister appearance of any
other species is the fact that they
serve as guards everyone has broken the
rules at some point as a kid and been
punished for it so everyone can relate
to this fear of getting caught by these
dark authority figures even if they know
that they haven't done anything wrong
when the punisher is a 10 foot
reaper-like creature who sucks the light
and happiness out of the air senses your
fear and feasts on your soul
well
there isn't anything that could
conceivably be worse than that
it's scary to think that many believe
that the dementors are too severe of a
punishment for the prisoners in azkaban
some of the worst criminals in the world
if they can't handle the torture of a
dementor it's hard to believe that
anyone could
one of the most chilling aspects is that
once a dementor has sucked out your soul
you may go on living as an empty shell
never experiencing happiness again
dementors are rowling's manifestation of
a deep unrecoverable depression
unlike voldemort they will never
go away
thank you for sticking to the end of
this video let me know in the comments
if there are any creepy things in the
wizarding world that i failed to mention
and be sure to give me your ideas on
what non-horror franchise i could cover
in the next episode of creepy things my
name is sisi and if you love horror
you're in the right place on this
channel i do videos on a variety of
horror topics like things you missed in
horror movies and all dante creepypasta
where i write and narrate my own horror
stories dumbledore would like to remind
you to subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week bring that death back
for notifications and i'll see you in
the next one assuming
we both survived
[Music]
you